bien primero me veo obligada una vez más
a ser el portavoz de los franceses
porque como lo escuché señor marco con
su gobierno usted dice que el poder
adquisitivo de los franceses aumentó
pero yo sólo he visto franceses que me
han hablado de sus problemas con el
poder adquisitivo solo franceses que me
han dicho que ya no alcanzaban a pagar
las facturas al fin del mes y estas
personas consideran que han perdido el
poder adquisitivo durante estos cinco
años usted ha tomado decisiones usted
implantó el impuesto sobre el carbono lo
que agravó el precio de la gasolina
usted también decidió bajar ayudas que
eran esenciales para varios de nuestros
compatriotas sobre todo las ayudas a los
alquileres de vivienda yo quiero que el
poder adquisitivo sea la prioridad de mi
mandato si los franceses confían en mí
mediante tres medidas
bajar los cines puestos quiero bajar de
manera perenne
no con tiquetes de racionamiento no con
cosas temporales sino de manera siempre
la el impuesto sobre las ventas sobre la
energía de 20 a 5.5 por ciento porque
pienso que la energía es un bien de
primera necesidad quiero bajar este iba
sobre los combustibles y el gas de
electricidad
son 12 mil millones que les devolveré
hacia los franceses pero también les
devuelve de poder adquisitivo bajando la
los impuestos restituir una parte a los
viudos y a las viudas al quienes se les
retiró también favorece de eximir
del impuesto sobre la renta a los
menores de 30 años también haré una
ayuda para el segundo hijo para que las
parejas puedan para que los hogares
puedan aumentar sus ingresos y voy a
apoyar el valor trabajo el valor del
trabajo es revalorizar varias categorías
por ejemplo
el personal paramédico y los docentes
que están menos pagados que la cndh que
el promedio en europa de los aprendices
los estudiantes que trabajen ellos
tendrán un complemento de ingreso de 200
a 300 euros y también
el último sector en el cual intervendré
decir de las personas vulnerables porque
pienso que durante su ingenio han sido
muy maltratadas y en estas personas
vulnerables revalorizar la política
para ellos para ellas es decir duplicar
las ayudas y los subsidios para las
familias
monoparental es
también un subsidio para los adultos
discapacitados me refiero a la des
conjuga lización es para quienes conocen
mal este sistema es significa que si
alguien si usted tomó la decisión de
oponerse a este subsidio
independientemente de los ingresos del
cónyuge creando así una dependencia más
y también en cuanto a las jubilaciones y
la indexación de las pensiones
este es un tema que no fue respetado
durante los últimos cinco años